listening to film courage women
in really good movies we get even a
better understanding of ourselves and we
get some visual artistry I think I think
movies are the seneschal most art of our
time you get cinematography acting music
writing and when they all come together
you have have something that that that
really is a feast for the eyes are the
inlet and the emotions so we we learn to
be what it's like to be human how can we
be better persons we we want to
understand other people kind of what I
talk about in confessions of a movie
addict which is my life story with
everything but the movie stuff edited
out it's a book that just tells it up
about everything that's happened to me
in connection with my love of movies and
the experiences I've had as a film
critic and the with interviewing stars
and directors and screenwriters and so
if you want a lot of laughs that's the
book that's the book to order